Hello everybody. This is section three of the beating chronic line book. I hope you're learning something from this and this is
making you look at line disease, maybe just a little bit different.
That's important. This section you're learning about giving it line, it's due.
There's some credit that this little bugger needs to be given because it is nasty little thing to deal with.
So some questions. Why is it so hard to kill?
So first of all, line is a gram-negative bacteria. Now a gram-negative bacteria is named so because
the way it stains with what's called a gram-stain, what you look at it at a slide.
The reason why it stains differently than a gram-positive bacteria is because there's a difference in the bacteria cell wall.
So the cell wall, the cell membrane of a gram-positive bacteria, see that this slide to the left?
We will talk about the gram-negative bacteria as a one that we have interest in.
The gram-negative bacteria has another membrane around that cell membrane.
And it is a membrane filled with what's called a lipopolysaccharide.
The lipopolysaccharide is a type of fat sugar combination.
We will get into the organic chemical component of it.
But it's important to note because if you kill a gram-negative bacteria, you liberate a lipopolysaccharide.
Now understand, if we're trying to kill cancer cells, you have that cancer cell is lysine or any other thing that you're trying to kill.
A virus or bacteria, you're breaking down that cell of that organism and you liberate what are called endotoxins.
An endotoxin means a toxin from within, meaning that it isn't like a toxin exposure to heavy metals or something like that.
It's an exposure because of your killing cells within your body.
So even waste given off by cellular metabolism is a type of endotoxin.
So our liver is made to deal with these endotoxins and we get rid of them through our liver detox pathways like you'd get rid of any toxin in our body.
But the problem with gram-negative bacteria is that is the lipopolysaccharide.
The lipopolysaccharide, once liberated, can elicit and immune response by itself.
So when I'm killing a cancer cell, when I have waste of normal metabolic waste from a healthy cell or when I kill a gram positive bacteria, I'm not liberating lipopolysaccharides.
And my immune system is typically not turned on against that waste.
So take a step back. What does my immune system do?
Your immune system is really meant to kill things.
You have really two sides of your immune system that we'll talk about in depth when we talk about an autoimmune issue.
But the main side of the immune system that kills things is called your TH1 response.
It is made up of a conglomeration of chemokines and cytokines and macrophages and white blood cells that really it's made in responsibility is to kill things.
So it turns on when there is an infection, when there is an infiltration of a pathogen to a point where the immune system is to turn on to kill that.
So you fire a TH1 response in the presence of a pathogen for the one in only purpose to kill that pathogen.
The problem with the gram-negative bacteria is if you do kill it, even with antibiotics or some sort of nutritional program or a rife machine or anything you're using to kill a gram-negative bacteria, you are liberating endotoxins in the form of lipopolysaccharides that can stimulate a immune response.
That's really important because if you kill a gram-negative bacteria too quickly, you will stimulate a huge endotoxin lipopolysaccharide infiltration into the bloodstream and your immune system will go wild.
So you can create an autoimmune issue by killing this too quickly.
So eventually when you have a lot of them in your body, that's why it's so important to catch this so quickly with a data biotic.
So the more it proceeds to replicate in your body, the greater amount of lipopolysaccharides that you're going to liberate in the greater chance that you're going to fire in a muter reaction that's going to cause a huge inflammatory response in different parts of your body.
So it's hard to kill because it's a gram-negative bacteria, but there's also a multitude of co-infections that go with it.
Even here's the four made co-infections of the Borrelia, but even in these four made co-infections, there's multiple sets underneath each one of these.
So like I have said in my set of testing kit that I use for a live disease, there's over 100.
So it's just, it gets really messy when you're trying to kill live, you're not just killing the Borrelia, you're killing all these other things as well.
So remember there's three faces of live, the acute stage, that's what it's still in the blood and in the extracellular spaces that it has not yet go into a cell inside of a cell.
Chronic stage is really when the first bacteria has entered into a cell, autoimmune system stage is when you have an autoimmune response.
You're starting to kill self tissue because you're now creating antibodies against self tissue because your immune system couldn't find the live and we'll talk about that in depth.
Remember what I said about acute stage live, get it treated with antibiotics, that's my belief right off the bat.
You have a window of opportunity that is going to close quite quickly.
With Chronic stage live, that's not yet autoimmune, you have some other choices.
So this is where people will argue with you, maybe you don't know it, but you have autoimmune stage live.
You've tried all these different possible helps like cat's claw and vitamin C and garlic and janina, and it's just, you feel better for a few days and then you seem to crash.
It just never seems to work, you'd ever get beyond a certain stage and you just keep crashing, you just feel like a yo-yo.
As you know, your best friend had live disease, they used cat's claw and doctor it right out and they were just fine.
Well because they caught it in the Chronic stage, you might not be in the Chronic stage.
If you're having trouble by using immune stimulators, vitamin C, cat's claw, echinacea, garlic, olive leaf extract, et cetera that are great immune stimulators, you might already be autoimmune.
That's a huge sign that you're autoimmune, we're going to discuss this at length, so stay with me with this.
Alright, I hope you're getting a lot out of this, we got so much more to do, I'll see you at the next section.